Tamura shigaraki is an amazing villain
those are words that I never thought I'd
say
especially since early on in the boku no
hero story I thought that she got rocky
was just an emo edge Lord with an
almighty complex and I thought that
stain and all-4-one were far superior
villains but as the boku no hero story
has progressed shigaraki has also
progressed and evolved at first she
gerak his progress was very slow and
barely noticeable but eventually that
progress really picked up steam
especially after the arrest of all-4-one
and at this point in the story she rocky
has become a terrifying villain both
physically and psychologically in this
video I will be tracking the evolution
of shigaraki from a tantrum throwing
manchild to a powerful villain commander
and a psychotic angel of destruction I
will be breaking down the evolution of
his powers and of his personality and I
will also explain why I think that
Shigure Aki may be the one to eventually
kill all might and bring the entire hero
Society to its knees if you enjoy the
boku no hero content right here on the
channel and you want us to keep it going
please leave a like to let me know it
really does help and if you happen to be
new to anime uproar please don't forget
to subscribe and hit that notification
bell to turn on all notifications you
can also hit me up on Twitter and
Instagram at anime uproar for all the
latest boku no hero news and updates
finally this video will contain MHA
manga spoilers i'm going to be
discussing all the latest information
that we have about shigaraki
and the evolution of his quirk and his
personality so that means that I'm
definitely going to go beyond the anime
with that said please proceed with
caution
you have been warned when we first meet
shigaraki he is a violent and creepy
manchild who sees everything in life as
a game and who throws tantrums when
things don't go his way he is entitled
selfish and arrogant and it is cleared
that he puts no value on the life and
well-being of others he has no
leadership skills and he doesn't treat
anyone with respect not even his own
allies the only person that she kuraki
actually respects is
his mentor all-4-one all-4-one rescued
shigaraki from a highly traumatic
situation back when she gerak he was
still a child and as a result Shigure
aki is loyal to over 1 for some reason
all-4-one has designated shigaraki as
his impending successor and all-4-one
has shown a lot of faith and confidence
in Shigure aki even after he continues
to underperform and fail in most of his
tasks in fact at the start of the series
it is hard for anyone to understand why
all for one the undisputed ruler of the
japanese underworld would waste his time
on an emo edge lord like shigaraki on
top of that it is even harder to
understand why all for one wouldn't
force shigaraki to put on some damn
chapstick for the love of anyway when we
first meet him she Guara keys only goal
and borderline obsession is to kill all
might who is the symbol of peace
shigaraki hates the hero society because
it is a society in which everyone relies
on heroes for everything and people no
longer take personal responsibility when
he was suffering as a child she got aki
was hoping that someone would help him
but everyone just ignored his suffering
and because they assumed that a hero
would take care of it why would they
have to do anything if helping others
was a hero's job eventually it was all
for one who found shigaraki and helped
him it took a villain to help a
suffering child because the regular
people didn't want to take
responsibility and the heroes were
nowhere to be found
since she Guara Kesey's all might as the
symbol of the hero society and all its
flaws his first instinct is to lash out
at the society that he believes failed
him by killing the greatest hero that
the society has to offer which is of
course all might however as the story
progresses both suga Rocky's personality
and his goals change shigaraki goes from
an arrogant tantrum throwing edge lord
to a powerful villain leader and a truly
unhinged the machine of destruction his
goals also change as he stops obsessing
over all might and focuses his attention
on destroying the hero society as a
whole so that he can one day reshape it
in his own image but before we can fully
understand shigaraki evolution and the
shocking evolution of his quirk we have
to understand his tragic and traumatic
story back when he was a young boy
Tamura shigaraki then known as tanka
Shimura was just a regular kid living in
a close-knit and relatively wealthy
family
young Tenko was a kind and friendly boy
who was close to most of his family
including his sister Hana
interestingly enough tanco had several
important similarities to the
protagonist of boku no hero is Akuma
Doria including the fact that a young
Tenko also wanted to one day become a
parole hero in fact young tenko got in
trouble several times for pretending to
be a hero in public none of this is
particularly surprising or strange for a
kid his age but tank o's father
Kotaro jamuna hated the idea of his son
wanting to be a hero and so inside the
shin when a household there were strict
rules against tankles pretend heroics
every time the five-year-old tanco
attempted to be a hero even just for fun
his father would punish him by forcing
him to stay outside in the backyard
alone without dinner or even slapping
him in the face and other forms of abuse
tank o's abuse at the hands of his
father was deeply traumatic to him and
he felt as if his own home the home
where he grew up was constantly
rejecting him and negating his innermost
wishes tanco also deeply resented the
fact that his mom's sister and his mom
parents who all lived at the house did
not interfere to prevent his father from
abusing him the reason why tank o's
father was so against his son becoming a
hero was his own experience with his
mother na na Shimura all meit's former
mentor na na Shimura was a pro hero who
abandoned her family in order to pursue
heroics she left her family because as a
pro hero she made many powerful enemies
and she did not want her family to
become a target for those enemies nana
was eventually killed by all-4-one and
it is clear that her son caught ro
Shimura
deeply resented the hero lifestyle and
how it took his mother away from him
this is why Cortado never wanted his son
Tenko to become a hero and while we can
sympathize with his sentiment being a
hero is very dangerous and it can put
even the hero's family in danger Kota
Rose treatment of his five-year-old son
is definitely unaccepted
he's just a kid and I'm sure every kid
in the world of MHA fantasizes about
being a hero at one time or another
being a hero is just such a natural
thing for a little kid to aspire to
become but just because a five-year-old
expresses a desire to do something it
doesn't mean that they will actually end
up doing it when I was five I wanted to
be an astronaut go to the moon and bring
cool moon flowers back to earth spoiler
alert I did not become an astronaut and
there are no flowers on the moon one
night after his father beat him and left
him outside in the backyard on his own
tanco was devastated this latest episode
happened because his sister Hannah
invited him into his dad's office to
look at pictures of his grandma who was
a hero but later when she was caught
Hana blamed the tenko for everything to
escape punishment herself tanco was
incredibly sad and filled with hatred
for everyone for his father who abused
him for his sister who betrayed him and
threw him under the bus and for his
mother and maternal grandparents who
stood by and allowed the abuse to
continue as tank o's dog came up to him
and tenko began to pet him his quirks
suddenly awakened and the dog was almost
instantly disintegrated by tank o's
decaying quark tank Oh sister Hana
approached her brother to apologize for
throwing him under the bus earlier but
as they both saw what happened to the
dog
they both freaked out tango thought that
they were being attacked by a villain
and he reached out to his sister for
help but then she was brutally
disintegrated as well as his mom and
grandparents emerged from the house
Danko's de canker spread through the
ground reaching them and destroying them
all at this point ANCA was still
confused about what exactly was
happening and of course he was terrified
although he later thought that he may
have known even then what he had just
done but when his father finally emerged
from the house tanco knew exactly what
he was doing he deliberately attacked
his father and grabbed his father's face
in order to kill him in the act of
killing his father didn't feel terrible
it felt great after killing his entire
family the five-year-old tanco found
himself just walking around the city
lost and alone
multiple people noticed him and they
could see that something was wrong with
him they could see that he needed help
but they all thought that a hero or a
police officer would take care of it
instead of them they just went about
their day as Tenko continued to wander
the town alone filthy and clearly
traumatized and disturbed it appears
that the heroes and the police had other
priorities because the person who
eventually found tanco hiding under a
bridge was none other than all for one
all for one took tanco in and with the
help of the doctor Fujiko he turned
tanco into the villain Tamura shigaraki
the name Tamura comes from the word
tomorrow which means to mourn a symbol
that Tamura is mourning the death of his
former self
tanka Shimura and the name shigaraki
comes from all for one's own real family
name which is apparently shigaraki
when all for one first took to Munna in
he was so traumatized that he suppressed
his memories and he was also
subconsciously suppressing the power of
his quirk he was highly mentally
unstable and in order to help him cope
Fujiko made his villain costume out of
the real hands of Tomas family and other
people that he killed it is beyond
bizarre and morbid but for some reason
this actually made Tom wanna feel better
and more stable as a person it is only
in chapter 237 and onward that shigaraki
retains his memories and once again
unlocks the full potential of his
decaying quirk in the past he could only
decay something that he touches with all
five fingers but during his battle
against the special abilities Liberation
Army he unlocks the ability to
disintegrate his targets without needing
to use all five fingers and the power of
his quirk is fully unleashed so that
when used the decay will quickly spread
from one object or person to another and
soon everything that is physically
connected to the initial target is
destroyed as well this allows shigaraki
to quickly disintegrate everything in
sight including large amounts of enemies
and entire buildings and city blocks his
quirk thus goes from a limited
close-range quirk to an incredibly
powerful long-distance and wide-ranging
quirk but his quirk isn't the only thing
that has evolved after regaining his
suppressed memories and his
pressed abilities she Guara keys true
dark nature is also unleashed shigaraki
has become confident fearless and bent
not only on killing all might but on
destroying the entire hero society and
reshaping it according to his own
desires shigaraki has also developed
effective leadership qualities and he is
now both feared and respected as the
leader of the newly formed paranormal
Liberation Front as such she kuraki is
currently at the head of an entire
villain army an army that has sworn its
loyalty to him and he has also gained
the respect of people who have doubted
him in the past including ug co and
gegen toh macchia most importantly
shigaraki is now liberated both
internally and externally he has no more
regrets about what happened to his
family or about his traumatic childhood
he has no more doubts about his
abilities or his plans for the future
and if that wasn't enough she kuraki
agreed to have buco perform an operation
on him that will give him the ability to
attain even greater power than all for
one an operation that will give him the
ability to one day absorb even one for
all
Fujiko warned shigaraki that this
procedure will take four months and will
cause unbelievable pain and suffering
but this did not face shigaraki in the
least he is determined to become as
strong as possible and bring the hero
society to its knees with how much
stronger shigaraki has become recently
and how much darker his psyche has
become I have to say that she karate has
evolved into an amazing villain in some
ways she gerak his growth as a character
eerily parallels the growth of Deku as
kids both boys wanted to become heroes
but a major obstacle was standing in
their way in dec whose case it was the
lack of a quirk and in Shiga Rocky's
case it was his father
it's interesting how just one factor
made such a big difference in the lives
of these two boys that factor is the
fact that Deku had a supportive mother
while she kuraki had an abusive father
the support of his mother allowed Deku
to overcome challenges including daily
bullying until he found himself in a
situation where he could achieve his
lifelong dream of becoming a hero
meanwhile the abuse of Sheikh Iraqis dad
drove the impressionable five-year-old
to the
brink of madness and his traumatizing
experience awakened shigaraki squirt and
led to the death of his entire family
Dec who was eventually discovered and
mentored by Almighty and shigaraki was
discovered and mentored by all four one
one is determined to become the greatest
hero while the other is determined to
become the greatest villain you've heard
the famous Joker quote all it takes is
one bad day and for shigaraki that day
came when his quirk awakened after his
father beat him and left him out in the
backyard alone and so instead of
continuing on to be an idealistic
wannabe hero like Deku XI gerak he
became a dark angel of destruction a
maniacal villain bent on crushing the
hero society to dust with his bare hands
and that really makes you think
if both dec when she got rocky started
out with such similar childhoods could
Deku become another shigaraki if he had
been faced with similar hardship cadet
who one day have his own bad day perhaps
the day that she got rocky finally kills
all might and could this one bad day
turn Deku into a completely different
person this is the beauty of Chicago
keys character at this point in the
story he has progressed greatly he has
evolved as a person and his quirk has
also evolved dramatically and he has
become not only physically but also
psychologically untethered Unleashed
shigaraki 'he's awakened quirk is
terrifying
the additional powers that he may soon
gain as a result of giucose operations
are also terrifying but shigaraki state
of mind his unleashed villainous
psychopathy is the most terrifying thing
of all the new shigaraki has no mental
blocks and barriers he has no confidence
or abandonment issues he is a pure
villain mastermind with no regrets no
doubts and no boundaries he is exactly
where he wants to be and he is doing
exactly what he wants to do he is the
anti Deku the anti protagonist and he is
an enthusiastic agent of chaos and
destruction I can't wait to see where
the story of shigaraki takes us next
but let me know what you guys think do
you agree that she karate has undergone
a massive development as a character and
a villain and do you now consider him to
be a serious threat to all might and the
entire hero society also who is your
favorite villain in the series and has
your opinion of shigaraki changed over
the course of the story let me know down
in the comments below
if you enjoyed this video you want to
see more videos like it please leave a
like to let me know and if you happen to
be new to anime uproar don't forget to
subscribe and hit that notification bell
to turn on all notifications seriously
the only way the YouTube will actually
notify you is if you go through the
trouble of hitting the bell and
selecting the option that says all
notifications you can also hit me up on
Twitter and Instagram at anime uproar I
want to give a big thank you to all of
our anime out pro patrons who make
videos like this one possible special
thank you to all of our pro hero tier
patrons including the one and only
Gilgamesh nothing but a fan Jason Wilson
King zelgius on hell cruise stealers
poet Pablo
atropos Wraith fitted alibied a karate
Gian Anatole Cassatt's ki DJ Nathaniel
and alpha do and I can't forget the ones
that rise above all other clans a
massive thank you to all of our the one
tier patrons including in grata alone
Adam Maddie Mac makoto-kun
and your voice Seth if you enjoy our
videos and you think that they add some
value to your life
consider supporting us on patreon even a
single dollar will give you access to
our patron exclusive discord and your
name will appear in our videos along
with these amazing people as always
thank you guys so much for watching and
until next time see us bass cowboys
[Music]